hey it's casserole or with et we are
hanging out in the studio with the
lovely the beautiful the talented Carly
fierce Carly how are you I'm so good how
are you I'm doing good I'm so excited to
talk to you because we have been teasing
and talking about your upcoming
sophomore album for so long
it's right around the corner February
14th I mean how are you feeling I really
can't believe that it's here but I am so
so so ready and so like just I just want
everybody to hear everything and want to
get this music out and getting stories
out and start playing alive well luckily
I mean we've already gotten four tracks
that have already been released and I
mean what what has been your mindset
going into this album maybe as opposed
to the first time around I think I'm
just more sure of myself and sure of who
I am in in the format and my place in
country music so I feel like I'm coming
into this with like a little bit more
confidence and more happiness I was
gonna say you could I have had a sneak
peek listen at the album and you can
tell you can tell that being in love has
played a part in this album oh my gosh
it's the heartbeat of the album and it's
the reason why I feel like so many of
these songs came to be and why so much
of my story has just being the girl got
her heart broken yeah is evolving he's
helped me to of all yeah from every
little thing to this it's like a whole
circle I love it we're so happy for you
and of course you know this 13 song
collection was produced by your late
friend and producer Busby when you guys
finish this album what did he say to you
cuz I know just by his social media I
don't know him personally but you could
tell he was so proud of you yeah oh gosh
he signed me when I was an artist that
had had a record deal and nobody wanted
anything to do with me in 2015 and so to
see it all come full circle we wrote so
many of those songs together we wrote
every little thing together when we got
to the end of this album I think both of
us just kind of looked at each other we
were like this album is gonna take you
to the next level and this is gonna make
you really just be able to stamp your
place in country music and a lot of
people don't know but literally like day
after he turned in my album was when he
found out that he had brain cancer and
it's the last body of work that he ever
finished and that feels like he almost
just was able to he helped me get the
wings and fly and now I get to carry his
legacy on and a lot of this album did
you guys work on it here in California
hmm is that emotional for you to be back
here and kind of do you feel this
presence oh my gosh I feel in a lot we
were more than just co-workers or Co
writers or producer artists we were
friends we were family
yeah and it feels a little different to
be back here we recorded a lot of that
this record in Altadena and it's
something that is bittersweet for me and
something that I think you know as the
album comes out and as I continue to
talk about it it'll hopefully just
continue to shine light on him do do you
get signs that he's near I feel I've
asked Michael actually the same question
about his grandfather
so the pennies the penny thing with his
family and the feather with mine for my
grandfather with Buzzbee I it's so
interesting the night that he or the day
that he passed away we didn't know until
later that evening but my mom had had a
dream about him the night before and he
was an amazing pianist and then he was
playing in a room and I felt like that
was like a weird sign for me and I I do
I feel him and it's fun to have him
around and my music I feel him all the
time and I'm sure you are making him so
proud I mean like I said four songs from
this album are already out one of them
being your collaboration with lee Brice
that is officially top 20
congratulations especially as a female
in country music to break through on the
radio and be in the top 20 and I feel
like this song is only going to continue
to climb how are you in Lee celebrate I
know it just made it official but we
we've been texting back and forth I mean
this is my fastest song to get into the
top 20 it's pretty crazy
it's so good but it's all good
it's just awesome and I lovely I didn't
know Li well before this but I just had
a feeling like one of those gut feelings
that's hit that's the voice that's who I
need on this song and he just is able to
emot-- in a way but obviously I wrote
the song with Luke Combs but Lee just
took it vocally somewhere that like I
didn't even know it could go yeah and
just to be on a song that I wrote that's
my story having all this happen with
somebody that I respect so much as an
artist and a songwriter is so fun I love
that and honestly though like you're you
to your voices it's like the duo that we
never knew we needed cut your music I
love it so we have four songs already
out there's 13 songs on the album and
you've been teasing that there might be
one more coming before the official
album release yes well lucky for our
fans you have brought a little gift you
have about a 10 second sneak peek
preview of one of Carly's upcoming
newest songs from the album it is called
hearts going out of its mind
take a listen
[Music]
now you actually you are a writer on
this song
I feel like did someone by the name of
Michael Ray happen to I inspire this one
I wrote that song three days after our
first day this song where I went in and
I was like I know that I sound
completely crazy but I feel like I just
had my first date with my husband and
they all were like whoo and I'm like
okay well here's the big kicker
it's Michael Ray and they're like what
but we wrote this song so fast and it's
that little I feel like your songs are
babies and markers and your life and
that was like the marker where I knew I
knew immediately oh you knew right away
that he was the one I feel like he would
say the same about you as well I hope so
what did he say when he listened to that
song for the first time knowing that he
was like it's raesha behind it I sent it
to him I emailed it to him we were both
out on the road and I just said hey I
wrote this today and I said I can't get
you out of my head and sent it to him
and he left it and that was like a fun
little way for two artists songwriters
to like flirt with each other when he's
in songs back and forth but that was the
one that made the record and I always
was like I hope that this works out
because I love this song you guys also
to have a song together which is
something you told us back at the CMAs
that he would be on the album look
younger
Oh your track finish your sentences I
mean it is it is just like it will give
you butterflies
I mean why that song in particular
because actually you guys did not write
this one this one is a familiar phrase
written and this one this is written by
two familiar faces I should say at
Kelsea Ballerini and Thomas Rhett behind
this track so why that one when I heard
it Thomas and my label head Scott
Borchetta sent it to mean obviously
Kelsey's a friend yeah and I heard it
and I felt like for this album the
heartbeat of the record is the fact that
we we were dating and we fell in love
and because we are married we're gonna
have our love moment we're gonna have
those moments to have those really big
heartfelt love song duets mm-hmm but
that isn't the stage of life that we
were in during
this album and when I heard finisher
sentences just the unique way that they
intertwined phrases and they really do
finish each other sentences I was kind
of mad that I'd never thought of that a
common phrase that we say but it really
felt like the beginning of our story and
kind of the the start of our duet
singing situation and there's also like
a line tune I don't want to give too
much away about like drinking wine and I
was like that sure that you guys didn't
write this up for me I have you to
actually like sitting down like sat down
and written a song together yet we
haven't okay we haven't all got the rest
of your life well and I think it'll
happen super organically obviously we
sing together a lot he actually sings at
home a lot more than I do
haha he would die if he knew that his
suitcase was gonna be that is not nice
it's he so who's the quit like the the
super tidy one at home okay that's how
he's not bad he just he is not a very
clean Packer so when we posted that
photo I was like I'm sorry that I'm
exploiting you okay life on the road
right I mean you guys have been married
for just over three months right
how is newlywed life it's it's great it
I don't know I feel like not much has
changed in the sense of we already live
together and but it's it's sweet when
you can just make that promise to each
other and and it's your best friend and
you you know that you have somebody
that's always there in your corner and
just promised you forever do you guys
have like rules for your marriage now
because you guys are touring artists and
you're very busy
do you have something where you're like
we can't go more than two weeks without
seeing each other or what not like you
have to like FaceTime at least like once
a day when you're apart or anything like
that we talk a lot like some people
don't talk all day or anything but we
text all the time even if somebody can't
respond we always send each other notes
and we don't like to go to movies
without seeing each other it just
doesn't breed for good I want to say
that Keith Urban has that rule too yeah
I could be wrong but I
gets him in Nicole and hey look at them
they they were yeah I feel like all the
girls in country music
Kelsey Marion we've all kind of like
kept tabs and you for like two weeks
just yeah not good for you
you need to you need to be able to yeah
great those boundaries but I think until
you're in this situation you I feel like
we're still trying to figure out what is
our rhythm what is our normal I love
that you just mentioned Kelsey and Marin
because it reminds me of the photo that
you guys posted not too long ago of each
other you guys had like a little gia
know a girls night out
are you so excited to be auntie Carly it
was really funny that particular night
she told us that they she told us when
she wanted to get pregnant okay she was
able to do that but you know when you
have a schedule like hers you have to
plan it out but we were like oh my gosh
that's so awesome and I'm so happy for
her and everything that's going on for
her yeah it's gonna be like the most
musical baby ever oh my god I know I
mean her and Ryan the kid of Ryan herded
Mary Morris I mean I'm she is genuinely
one of the nicest yeah heart of the
girls so I'm she's gonna be a great mom
and so are you one day oh you might yeah
I need to get to Marin status okay you
know I will say you know obviously a
friend of a friend I've known you for a
while
I saw your insta story the other day and
it was like not drinking for a while and
I was like I mean it could be dry
January I was like oh I was like oh does
she have something to share but because
I did a mess a dry January I said not
drinking for a while yeah so I felt like
I would like fun and I was like listen
just try January I'll be back next month
oh my god I could no it's so funny I
mean what so what is in store like
obviously 2024 you and Michael gonna be
very busy you're about to you know hit
the road with Old Dominion you have some
dates with them you know what's in store
for the Rays um for the right I know I'm
legally just changed your name right
yeah yes I it's gonna be busy a new
album just of getting to really dive
into that and and put that my heart and
soul now gets to be given to all the
country fans
very busy year touring more than I can
tell you yet and obviously just enjoying
and finding my balance with my personal
life I never really had a personal life
before I didn't really have a reason to
go home and now I do now you have a
whole husband now I got a whole husband
oh-hoh husband and Carly peers
congratulations on everything both
personally and professionally it's
always great to see you shining yeah you
guys Carly's sophomore album self-titled
is coming out February 14th trust me
I've listened to it you are not gonna
want to miss it and of course her songs
that are already out now oh thank you so
much thank you
[Music]